this video will continue to explore the
sound system of Spanish as an example
for understanding phonology more
generally last time we looked at
consonant and vowel phonemes and
allophones this time we're going to work
through the stress in syllable structure
in Latin American Spanish let's look at
further sets of words in Spanish this
time paying attention not to the
phonemes or to the allophones of those
homes but to this stress see see oh
holla holla holla
kwinto kwinto Olivia Olivia Olivia the
words on the right hand side are marked
with an asterisk and they don't exist in
Spanish so how does stress work in
Spanish to push you in the right
direction we find that accent plays some
role in Spanish but moving the accent to
a different syllable doesn't always
generate a new word some syllables are
stressed but others are unstressed let's
ask a more basic question how do
syllables work in Spanish in the IPA for
language learning we looked at possible
syllable types now we move on to some
examples that give us a sense of the
phonotactics the syllable structure of
Spanish
espero Estrella yo si lo say baile de
plana para trás may fall toss to la
palabra float I've given you examples of
Spanish accentuation and syllable
structure but what's going on here is
accent contrastive in Spanish meaning do
we find minimal pairs that differ in
accent placement only reducing syllables
to consonant and vowel what types of
syllables exist in Spanish
please join me next time to start
learning about rules and environments